-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
This is it. You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a crowd right there.
-Come on!
-Let's get to some news here.
Well, guys, even though
vaccinations are up,
studies show that a lot of
white, conservative men
don't want to get vaccinated.
And now The White House is
trying to convince them
to get a vaccine
by advertising on
NASCAR, CMT,
and "Deadliest Catch."
That's right -- NASCAR, CMT,
Basically,
Larry the Cable Guy's DVR.
Yeah, and if this plan fails,
The White House
is just gonna include
the vaccine
with every pack of Slim Jims.
I think "Deadliest Catch" can
actually reach Conservatives.
Although more careful viewers
will be like,
"Before making a decision,
I want to get a second opinion
from the 'Wicked Tuna' guys."
That's right -- The White House
is using shows like
"Deadliest Catch"
to try and reach out to
vaccine-hesitant Americans.
Well, I was watching
TV last night,
and I think they may be involved
with another show, as well.
-Really?
-Take a look at this.
-Okay.
-I'd like to
solve the puzzle, Pat.
-Go ahead.
-"Get the vaccine,
you [bleep] morons.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really?
-I'd never seen
anything like that.
-Wow!
-I'd never seen
anything like that.
-I've never seen
this foul language.
-I've been watching
television for years.
-For a long time.
I've been watching television --
-And I've never
seen anything like that.
-I've never seen anything
like that.
-Yeah.
-That's disgusting.
-That's also
a good message maybe.
-Good messaging,
yeah, but, still, rude.
-Well, everyone was
talking about this.
Today, the CDC and FDA
made a big vaccine announcement.
Listen to this.
-The CDC and the FDA
have issued a joint statement
recommending a pause
in the use of
the Johnson & Johnson vaccine.
They are reviewing
six reported cases of
a rare type of
blood clot in people
who have received the vaccine.
-That's right --
they're recommending a pause.
Then anyone who's ever been
dumped was like, "Oh, boy.
We know what 'pause' means."
-Nothing to do with
your Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-It's a family show.
-Yeah, Johnson & Johnson.
Yeah, the vaccine.
What did you -- Oh.
-Oh.
-Get your mind
out of the gutter.
I don't go for
that kind of humor.
-Johnson & Johnson
is owned by the same family
who owns the New York Jets,
so don't think of
this as a pause.
Think of it more like
a 50-year rebuild.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And today, if you had
a Johnson & Johnson appointment
in New York,
they gave out Pfizer instead.
Yeah. It's like going to
a restaurant and hearing,
"Oh, we're out of Coke.
Is Dom Pérignon okay?"
After the news broke, Dr. Fauci
spoke at The White House
and had this to say to people
who have recently received
the Johnson & Johnson vaccine.
-First of all,
don't get an anxiety reaction.
If you look at what
we know so far,
there have been 6 out of the
6.85 million doses,
which is less than
1 in a million.
-Yeah. Fauci was like,
"Basically, the odds are
about the same as me getting
drafted into the NBA."
Seriously, Fauci has a
better chance of replacing
Regé-Jean Page in "Bridgerton."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You like that idea?
-Yeah.
Yeah, it's a really rare event.
It's like seeing a working
self-checkout machine at CVS.
-Oh.
-That's how rare.
That's how rare.
-That's rare.
-Well, guys, President Biden
signaled yesterday
that he's willing to
compromise with Republicans
on his infrastructure plan.
In fact, he's willing
to work with Republicans
on all sorts of issues,
and they're finding some pretty
interesting ways to compromise.
For example, Biden wants
to invest in high-speed trains,
while Republicans want
to increase military spending.
So their compromise is to send
Thomas the Tank Engine to Iraq.
-Oh.
Wow.
-Take a look at
this next compromise.
Biden wants to
raise the minimum wage,
while Republicans
want to win in 2024.
So the compromise is to
pay Trump 15 bucks an hour
not to run again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, finally, Biden wants to
decriminalize marijuana,
while Republicans want
to ease tensions with Russia,
so now they plan to get
stoned and drink vodka.
Well, at least
they're working together.
-That's the best one.
-Well, here's some
business news.
The C.E.O. of Uber
recently said the company
could start delivering weed
if it's decriminalized at
the federal level.
And Uber drivers are like,
"Right, we're going to 'start'
delivering...weed.
When you say so.
As soon as you say so,
we're going to
start distributing drugs.
But you tell us when, 'cause
we're making a fine living now.
We don't need to do stuff
like that."
Yep, soon, you can
order Uber Weed and Uber Eats
at the same time
and have them race.
Check this out.
I saw that Pinterest just added
new guidelines to encourage
its users to be
more positive and kind.
Pinterest. Yeah.
They made the decision
after someone kept
harassing people through quilts.
Meanwhile, things have
gotten so out of control,
over on Etsy,
they just started a fight club.
-Really?
-Yeah, absolutely.
Well, here's a crazy story.
Usher was being criticized
for tipping dancers
at a Las Vegas strip club
with fake money
that had his face on it.
Well, the club said that
it wasn't true,
but someone from Usher's team
did leave some of
the money behind.
Take a look. This is real.
Yeah.
In Usher's defense,
George Washington
did the same thing anytime
he went to a strip club.
-That's true.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, Usher is in hot water
after he went to
a Las Vegas strip club and used
fake money with his face on it.
But he's saying the whole thing
is a big misunderstanding,
so here now on the phone to
discuss the situation is Usher.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Usher, are you there?
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-Great. So...
-Okay.
-So you're saying this is
a big misunderstanding.
Is that right?
-♪ Yeah! ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Now, correct me if I'm wrong,
but the fake money
was for a promo,
but you actually
did pay with real money.
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-I see.
Well, I bet it felt
pretty bad when
people were dragging you
online for no reason.
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-But I understand you called
your friend Lil Jon for help.
What did he say
when you called him?
-♪ Okay! ♪
-Well, I hope everything gets
ironed out this week,
and thank you
for being here, Usher.
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-Alright, there you go.
Always nice to get the
last word in.
-Oh, yeah, had to do it.
-Well, this is interesting.
I read that a team of
researchers at MIT
unveiled new findings
that could lead to
communication with spiders.
-Ooh!
-If that works,
the scientists will move on to
their next task --
communicating with a human.
"Well, you see, the spider...
Uh, well, you know,
the spider is sort of pretty.
I mean, you're not pretty.
I mean, spiders aren't pretty.
You're pretty.
But, I mean,
I wouldn't say that you are.
You can have the --
You could take the spider
if you'd like to.
I'm just going to leave,
and you stay here in the lab.
I-I-I have to sit down."
Finally, I saw that
the movie "Magic Mike"
is being turned into
a reality show
where 10 men will undergo
a full-body evolution
and compete for the title of
The Real Magic Mike.
You know, after a year
of the pandemic,
I think we've all gone through
a full-body evolution.
Yep, the winner will receive
the prestigious title of
The Real Magic Mike
and the grand prize of
1 million Usher bucks.
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-We have a great show!